yikes aha
who let the dogs out woof whoa well
gingy yeah yeah this might be the
powerful idea hi guys welcome to this
video my name is grace Helbig if you do
not know now you know your life is
different now
Cheers um basically I'm having I'm
wildly hungover and I have to get ready
to go to a meeting today so I thought
I'd make a video that sort of a get
ready with me stream of consciousness
let's just talk and slap a bunch of my
face to make myself not look like this
face I have this cleansing water I got
this in a drugstore in London I think I
just use it all over my face I have this
thing where no matter how drunk I get I
can't go to sleep with my makeup on nine
times out of ten wake up in the middle
of the night you wash my face I know you
can't believe it okay
I just completely missed the trash then
I have this amazing product this is
first aid beauty's detox eye roller and
it's basically this little roller stick
of magic that is supposed to deep up
your under-eye area I don't know exactly
what's in it but it stings a little bit
so I feel like it does things you
believe I'm actually doing like
something kind of sincere to like what
makeup gurus do I've been using this
product is Neutrogena oil-free acne
correct and cover pink grapefruit
moisturizer I love using a tinted
moisturizer under my foundation feel
like it serves the purpose of a
moisturizer and a primer it does smell
like a grapefruit and it stings a little
bit like a grapefruit maybe like I just
like things that have you guys been
what's been going on a new team Kim 18
Taylor a lot of you thought that I was
shading them in my last video that I did
a Kim Kardashian and Taylor Swift mashup
inspired makeup love and there was no
shade I don't take a side in this
scenario I have opinions about it but
they're not
you know necessary for me to put out on
the Internet
you all thought that I was shading
Taylor or shading Kim was shading you
guys you guys put so many snakes on
their social media they're human beings
too like I know I bought a ton of new
beauty Shh here we go I'm having a great
time and so I'm very excited to try some
stuff out I don't even know what to try
out there's one thing I will start with
but I tried yesterday and I think love
it's this this is tarts lip facial it's
basically a lip scrub in this little
tube that you scrub on your lips
okay I'll scrub and then I don't usually
know what to do with the scrub after
it's been scrubbed on my lips neither
wash it off you can take it off with a
makeup remover wipe or you can eat it it
tastes really good we're just going to
leave that there for a second let's
start hiding bad you know that's just
life it's like successful people are
just better at hiding their bad hello
there's a fun tumblr quote for you
I bought this foundation this is
luminous silk foundation it's Giorgio
Armani and I bought the travel size
which I highly recommend buying travel
sized items of makeup when you are
buying line ly online because if you
hate it you don't to hate yourself for
buying a full-size product so we're just
smashing this huh
what else is going on in the world oh
just that it's falling apart yeah okay
that's a decent start let's cover under
our eyes our detox roller thing has
absorbed immediately because under eyes
just needs a lot of attention so I'm
gonna use this is NARS radiant creamy
concealer in Chantilly it's the lightest
color and I know so many of you are like
that's too light of a color for you but
like not today [ __ ]
I need this who's that girl while I was
watching that song that the girl's name
was Lola wah-wah so it's like Colin
responds like who's that girl oh that's
a la la la la la la and we smash this
okay Matt looks like something is lip
things really delicious now let's do
these eyebrows I use this on my eyebrows
Anastasio sprows eyebrow pencil and then
brush all in one brush Dembrowski r--'s
a fun thing later today I'm going over
to memory Hart's place to shoot a video
with her and you'll hear more about this
on Monday but I want to tell you now
Gina are going to be in Montreal next
week hosting a bunch of amazing stand-up
comedians at Just for Laughs the link to
tickets will be in the description of
this video but if you guys are in
Montreal we're hosting two shows it's
Thursday night yeah I'm pretty sure it's
Thursday night and there's so many
amazing stand-up comedians and we're
doing a little bit in the show so if you
live in or around Montreal please come
to one of the two shows again link will
be in the description these eyebrows are
excited too let's cut them with some
brow gel he's just yeah Phan estas yes
it's like the it's the thing that comes
with the other thing these eyebrows look
weird
okay now on to eyes this brush clean no
it's not I think there's one more thing
recently benefits world-famous neutrals
and it's just a bunch of like neutral
colors as to cream I in there sometime
take the white and highlight love that
they say if you put white and your inner
tear duct area it makes you look more
awake I can do your cotton head like you
know that kind of sexy imagery then I'm
gonna take this cream eye shadow called
bikini tini why I'm just gonna smear
this all over my eyelid is it seems like
a neutral champagne color that's what
we're going for drank a lot last night
so let's put some champagne on our
eyelids today Wow now let's try it
there's this other creamy eyeshadow in
here called holy smokes with an
exclamation point and it looks like this
and I'm gonna see if I can shade my eye
a little bit with this one don't use a
brush just gonna put this a little bit
in oh no way too much oh my god panic
toilet is way too much and immediately a
terrible place not the right not the
right choice it's not the right choice
is not the right choice this is how I
ordered drinks at a bar too
I should always like me it does not know
when to stop
yep let's see what happened everyday
some classic liquid winged liner I have
this NYX Cosmetics super skinny
eye marker which is just a black liquid
liner
and this is my posture for lining my
eyelid and usually I just lined both
lids and then at the wings at the end
they have caffeinated makeup someone get
me to shark tank now we had wings oh
look we got wings going right yeah we're
gonna do is really fun thing that I've
been doing a lot lately and you're gonna
see a lot of these products in my
favorites video later in the month
this is this Smashbox photo-finish lash
primer is a tube of crazy eyelash primer
so it's just white mascara basically
that you put on fur let dry and then you
put the black mascara or whatever color
you want on over Neath over nice and
then you put your mascara on overtop and
it helps create more volume than just
the mascara by itself so you put this
white mascara on and you let yourself
look crazy for a second and we let that
dry while that dries I'm gonna put some
bronzer on now I'm just straight up
talking to you about my makeup like I'm
not even talking to you about anything
else what else is going on
Trump okay I respect opinions but I have
a hard time respecting someone that
doesn't respect anyone else this there's
two phases chocolate Soleil its base its
bronzer that smells like chocolate I
think I've mentioned this before if they
have makeup that smells like chocolate
we can get cat being into makeup right
like that soon soon I don't have any
skin makeup brushes that's a fun thing
this is how I clean my makeup brushes
we're gonna use our bronzer to combat
the puffiness that we feel in our face
today
wow that's maybe do this a little bit
now throw some blush on I like use this
Bobbi Brown's illuminating bronzer
powder but this ain't no bronzer you
tell me that's problems as bronzer for
like a Fraggle
we got a human meat puppet right yeah
yeah cool fine enough now let's get less
crazy-looking and let's add some actual
mascara oh let me turn this this is
tarts tertius lash paint mascara now we
just smash this on top of the white I
like to put mascara on my bottom lashes
I know a lot of people don't but I like
to sit makes my eyes look like whoa my
eyes are open and I am listening
ish there's gotta be a photo series
right of like mascara applying faces
because like this is arc I mean look how
like that primer right wait there's a
face that's starting to look more like a
face and less like a dirty sock on top
of a body I mean I have sufficiently
eaten off my entire lip scrub tasted
great okay breakfast is done from all
along I'm gonna continue to drink coffee
but I'm gonna put a lip on so you guys
just get to see the full look oh yeah I
know I'm no beauty guru coos but let me
pretend we're gonna try just today from
bite and it is the pigment pencil called
Madeira which gives you an obvious
insight into what the color is it's just
this like nude pinky color I think
mine's a my mom's like Avon makeup which
is probably not a great way to sell any
white products but they're in nostalgia
tada who knows what this is better or
worse but I have painted my face I'm
going to do my hair now and go to a
meeting thank you for hanging out with
me today while I actually showed you how
I do my makeup isn't it weird that there
weren't any like for all the aspects to
this video I hope you guys have a great
weekend thank you for watching if you
enjoyed this video at all or if you
hated it at all please subscribe to my
youtube channel I like having you guys
here it's fun it gives me a reason
I don't know oh my dog one second hold
on
she takes priority you ready so hot you
are so amazing I'm just talking to my
internet friends okay I use this on my